In modern browsers, there is a cool
feature that you could use; autofill.
Users appreciate when
a website save them
time by automatically filling common
fields like name, email, and more.
Plus autofill helps to reduce
potential input errors
like what Cam experienced before.
Browsers use many heuristics to
determine which field they could
auto-populate based on a previously
specified data by the user.
You, the developer, can give hints
to the browser by providing both
the name attribute and the auto complete
attribute on each input element.
For example, to give the browser a hint
that it should auto complete the form
with a user's name,
email, and phone number.
You should use these
auto complete attributes.
Let's have a look on the name or
should I say the first name,
the input element has an AutoComplete
attribute equal fname.
On the email input,
we have the autocomplete equal email.
And on the phone input element,
I'll have the tell AutoComplete
like you could see here.
Let's see it in action.
When I start typing the address, you
could see that the browser is already
remember what was typed here before.
And now with a click on the enter,
I'm filling the shipping
address with just a few clicks.
Awesome.
In the instructor notes,
you could find a massive list
of auto-complete attributes.
Take a look and see how you could
automate life for your users.
And put a big smile on their faces.
Now it's your turn to add
some AutoComplete attributes.